[Music]
uh do you know musashi he was a samurai
in the 16th century i believe
anyway he wrote
what is called the path of aloneness
and there are 21 really simple
principles that i would consider to be
ascetic principles and i wanted to read
those to you today i figure we could
talk about these yeah and i don't want
to i want to be careful not to
prescriptionize these things but to
learn lessons from them and see how some
of them may be applicable how i might
want to take on this principle but not
this one or aspects of this principle to
have a better understanding
of what is making me suffer or making me
miserable in certain instances
and so the first one of his 21
principles we'll put a link to this in
the show notes
number one accept everything just the
way it is
um these are also called the 21 ways of
the samurai i believe but yeah i was
gonna ask so there's no religion backing
this this is no he i believe was a
buddhist but there is not a religious
component necessarily no okay so
this is from musashi number one is
accept everything just the way it is
there's sort of the that's like the
serenity prayer on steroids in a way
yeah it's not like grant me the courage
to change the things i can no it's
simply like
everything is how would it and there's a
saying in a
popular colloquialism in today's
vernacular it is what it is um yeah but
really accepting things for the way that
they are and we were talking about this
on the minimal episode but i thought we
could dive in a little bit more here
when it comes to
wanting other people's veneration or
validation or approval
if they approve of you they approve of
you i'm accepting it for how it is if
they don't i'm accepting it for how it
is
number two and this is a big one for me
that
i um
that has really just helped me with
respect to my own peace and contentment
number two is
do not seek pleasure for its own sake
and
we call this the pursuit of happiness
but of course the pursuit of happiness
is the path
to unhappiness yeah
and so
nothing wrong with pleasure pleasure is
a wonderful byproduct
of many things yeah but we're constantly
seeking pleasure we're scrolling through
tick tock and instagram more and more
and more more dopamine more butts more
cars more music more more more
it's making us miserable it ups our
threshold for more pleasure and it leads
to a hedonic lifestyle
that just is not sustainable long term
that's why we feel that dopamine dump we
feel drained we feel empty we feel
lonely even if we're not alone
number three
do not under any circumstance
depend on partial feelings
partial feelings like i'm partial to
this person this house this car
and
the the feelings nothing wrong with
having feelings but when we allow all of
our emotions to guide us we become like
a balloon if you blow up a balloon
and then just you're holding on to it
that's fine but as soon as you let it go
your feelings whip you around the room
you have no idea where they're going to
take you
number four
think lightly of yourself
and deeply of the world
maybe another way to say that is don't
take yourself too seriously
it's not all about you yeah
number five
be detached from your desire
your whole life long
good luck prescribing that to anyone
right
because really what musashi is saying
here is
the more we desire the more imprisoned
we are the more attached we become
the more we cling the more we cling the
more we suffer it's a rather buddhist
perspective right he takes it a step
farther and sort of these aren't
prescriptions from him he wrote these
last week of his life to sort of
really
display
how he had lived his life up until that
point
number six
do not regret what you have done
number seven never be jealous i think
these two sort of go together right they
become wasted emotions in a way now we
did a episode recently about consumer
regrets and we talked about the way to
let go of regret
it's pretty simple it's to learn the
lesson from the regret as soon as you
have an actual lesson that you feel
viscerally not just intellectually the
regret tends to dissipate
jealousy is similar in the respect that
it is a wasted emotion
jealousy might mean oh ryan had an
achievement now i wish i also had that
achievement right
and i'm not complete i'm not as good as
him he is better than me
because of that achievement yeah anytime
i feel jealousy it
i just have to stop and like
look at that symptom
instead of
like fostering that jealous feeling it's
more of like why am i jealous like what
am i getting upset about right what am i
feeling like i'm missing out on what is
it what is this emotion saying about me
and my current circumstance
and that um
it still is a wasted emotion but um it
is a valuable symptom for me this is the
multi-layer why that we were talking
about why am i jealous
and i think if we work through that's
one of those things we never do we don't
ever stop to ask why
it's the reason we start our last film
lessons now with the question
and it's a disguised question how might
your life be better with less
well what does that mean well it's
really like why
would you benefit from minimalism why
would you benefit from simplifying
what is your why
and because as soon as you understand
that why
it peels back these layers
and it's these the multi-layered why so
why am i jealous of if my wife
is attracted to
another person
it was because maybe it says something
about me okay what does it say about me
that i am
not enough for her well that's actually
true
yes i'm not enough for her she's already
enough i can't complete her she is
complete
without me
now that goes back to what he said
earlier think lightly of yourself
i've been taking myself too seriously
that's why i'm jealous
but recognizing as human beings we have
physical attractions to other human
beings
and we are also complete on our own and
so jealousy doesn't make a whole lot of
sense when i start peeling back those y
layers and we can even go deeper and
deeper and deeper
number eight never let yourself be
saddened by a separation
hmm now that could be saddened by a
separation with another person you're
spending time apart from someone or
maybe someone has gone a different way
and they're no longer talking to you
yeah or it could just mean that i'm
separated from a thing i used to have my
car got stolen right
and you can be saddened by that
but what he's saying is that doesn't
that sadness
is not productive in the sense that he's
not saying
renounce sadness you can experience
sadness right right but too often in our
culture we also seek out
certainty through these emotions that
make us feel
sad
lonely miserable etc
i'll do a few more here number nine
resentment and complaint are appropriate
neither for oneself nor others
the complaining thing is an odd one
because
it often helps us we think build
camaraderie with other people
oh can you believe the stupid politician
did that stupid thing
oh yeah man i hate stupid politicians
and stupid things you know what else i
hate right yeah and and now we're
bonding over our own
complaints mm-hmm right yeah and what
that does is it in australia what do
they call it tall poppy syndrome
you're familiar with this town
so like quite often like it's the one of
the ways that their cultures are
different from american culture where we
tend to celebrate the tall poppies
but in the in a field you actually cut
down the poppies so they're all the same
size well
and culturally in australia they tend to
cut down other people who
had whose head gets too big or their
achievements get too big or whatever
right i'm not saying that's right or
wrong
i would avoid
insulting other people to tear them down
so that my building is the same height
as them so to speak
number 10
do not let yourself be guided by the
feeling of lust or love
now
those are two different feelings
but love
is to see someone who for who they are
without trying to change them
and so in a way that can't guide you
anywhere because you're already there um
it actually takes you back to number one
except everything just the way it is
that's actually love
it doesn't drag you anywhere in fact it
helps you be peaceful and content
exactly where you are but then the lust
piece
is that's one of the harder ones lust is
a type of desire tends to be sexual
desire although we've
we have lust for consumer products now
um you know it's a problem we refer to
the iphone as it being sexy yeah it's a
sexy gadget right
that's a type of lust right
and lust makes us do some really
irrational irresponsible
harmful things yeah we've both done some
crazy things for lust
tell me about it
not on the podcast
all right let's do a few more here
number 11 and all things have no
preferences
oh
that is
that one i find tremendous wisdom in
that but i am certainly nowhere near
being able to actualize that yeah but
i think of our friend colin wright he's
the closest thing i know to an ascetic
he has very few preferences like i
remember we'd be on the road and he just
he would go with the flow
he would have no preferences the same
way a river has no preference it simply
goes where it goes
and the experience is whatever it is
and colin leads an amazing life because
he has very few preferences here's
another way to think about that
the more preferences
we have
the more discontent
comes along with those preferences yeah
the less peace we have and you know
there's something about
you know uh having few preferences
and him being able to fall asleep
anywhere
like not only
you know because he uh
he travels a lot so you know he finds
ways to like fall asleep like there's
the cutest picture of him on my
instagram where he like fell asleep in
the in the back of uh the corolla when
we were on tour yeah he looks like this
if you're watching the video version
he's like this yeah and i'm like robot
shut off yeah yeah his batteries ran out
but like but but there's something about
him
being at peace that allows him to fall
asleep like that
yes in fact that's actually the next
point here number 12 is be indifferent
to where you live
now
you can take this one of several ways
one is like colin
he could live literally he's lived
everywhere dude he lived in uh wichita
he lived in wichita he lived in iceland
he lived in india he had a camper
yes yeah and he lived for by the way for
two months straight he lived on
greyhound buses
he brought yonah he wrote a book about
this called iceland india interstate
yeah so he lived in iceland for four
months then he lived in
uh india for four months brought yonah
with him yeah and then he said i'm gonna
show yona america but the real america
let's take her on a greyhound bus to all
48 contiguous states
so he spent two months living on great
and so
he really epitomized
being indifferent to where you live and
when you are that indifferent then
everything is a surprise you don't need
all of these comforts so any comfort you
do get
is
you're overwhelmed with
with that as opposed to needing it
clinging to it
number 13
do not pursue the taste of good food
so this is the asceticism i'm not really
down with but uh dude that's like
that's one of the only
maximal things i have in my life
i have a pristine diet and it's really
um
it's really
well in fact i i got this here i printed
this text out maybe this would be a good
time to read this uh from dawn she
texted us and said hey um what would you
say
oh yeah
um josh try
vitamin b12 if you're still feeling low
energy you have may have an mthfrg
mutation uh yes i do uh 60 humans have
that and it just means you can't detox
toxins very well but it also means that
out of necessity my diet is pristine i
don't remember when i said i was low
energy probably when i was dealing with
some illness and i'm feeling appreciably
better my energy's been through the roof
lately in fact last night i had to stay
up really late and
even today i didn't get much sleep i
feel i feel great yeah and so it's
awesome um you're right though b12 there
are a bunch of other things that have
helped me out vitamin a
for energy and your immune system which
you can supplement with or you can get
from organ meats or
b12 you can get from muscle meats
all the b vitamins i've also been doing
a lot of sunlight spending time outside
but i have a pristine diet and it is
much more about nourishment than it is
about
entertainment mm-hmm
or pleasure mm-hmm
right for me food
can be pleasurable but it for me it
can't be
the
pleasure has to be a byproduct of food
for me yeah because
of this these autoimmune symptoms and
disease that i that i deal with
um if i don't have a pristine diet
i feel it immediately i pay the price
and for other people they can eat seed
oils for many decades and eventually it
may give them cancer
but you don't pay that price right away
if
i told you next time you had canola oil
you would get cancer there's no way
you'd ever eat canola oil right again
yeah right yeah
and yet that's not the way that
food works
there's this delayed effect but for me
it's much less delayed
i can eat something right now and feel
miserable two hours from now
and so
yes pursuing the pleasure in food
often leads us to a place where we
live an unhealthy life when i was
morbidly obese it was all about so so i
get what he's saying here
do not pursue the taste of good food
because that's what i did
when i was young and i was morbidly
obese i was the fattest kid you knew
ryan
and i pursued only pleasure now if i ask
myself why
well it's because i didn't have a whole
lot of certainty in other areas of my
life yeah and so
this was one of the few areas where i
could have certainty i'm certain that i
can please myself in the moment
but of course i didn't realize being a
young kid how much displeasure
dispossession that led to
in the long run or even in the you know
a medium run gaining a lot of weight but
also feeling sluggish
tired
unhealthy lethargic
those things were
yeah those were all excess it was a type
of accumulation
we'll put a link to this in the show
notes you can check out
uh all of them um all 21
of the principles in the path of
aloneness another one of them is do not
fear
death
that's a practical one because
you're not going to get out of here
alive did you enjoy this standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit
patreon.com the minimalists or click the
link in the description your support
keeps our podcast and youtube channel
100
advertisement free